we're doing this movie and it was pretty
low budge and I was doing a scene with
Viola and the director kept saying the
scene would stop when he'd say oh can
you do it um you can do it again and
I'll be like sure what do you want
because so I'm pretty much like that I
don't mind I love directions yeah money
but he wouldn't he wouldn't say
specifically what he wanted just do it
again just do it again and I thought
well it might be a bit different this
time so I would do it again and this
this happened about four times
and then uh
I said to him like listen I I mean you
got to be more specific I keep doing it
and I I don't know what you want and he
was very frustrated and he said I I just
want you to do it the way the guy that
did the auditions did it in the audition
the reader the reader and I said to him
well look we're about a weekend you can
always get him
get him and he can do it